[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrado
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana nos hacemos una
pregunta tan interesante como
inquietante dejar a esta pandemia de
coronavirus toda una generación de
jóvenes perdidos en américa latina'
vamos a intentar responder a esta
pregunta con cuatro invitados me
acompañan paola martínez infante
periodista independiente bienvenida
paola georges dive economista para
latinoamérica up de la aseguradora euler
hermes bienvenido george muchas gracias
carlos vino grado de la escuela de parís
económica de economía de parís de la
universidad devry y además fue ex
secretario de estado de argentina de
comercio bienvenido carlos
y me acompaña a distancia desde
barcelona- yanina pelp investigadora del
centro albert hirschman de ginebra y
coordinadora editorial de agenda pública
janina buenos días
buenos días la generación perdida de
jóvenes de américa latina como
consecuencia de la cob y 19 hoy en
primera plana
se cumplen seis meses desde que la
organización mundial de la salud declaró
el inicio de la pandemia y según avanza
por el continente de latinoamérica vamos
viendo consecuencias el cobro de vidas
también las consecuencias económicas y
consecuencias que vamos a ver también a
corto o medio plazo quizá como una
generación de jóvenes puede perderse lo
hemos visto con datos que van ofreciendo
por ejemplo el banco interamericano de
desarrollo que dice que cientos de miles
de jóvenes están abandonando las
universidades de américa latina y
realidades que inciden en este aspecto
como por ejemplo el desempleo juvenil o
la educación a distancia que aún ha
podido agravar las desigualdades hoy
incidimos en esa pregunta si puedes y
podemos estar ante una generación de
jóvenes perdidos en américa latina'
antes de ello vamos a repasar algunas
portadas como hacemos cada semana por
ejemplo el espectador reflexión en su
portada sobre una prioridad en medio de
esta pandemia titulando educar la
prioridad el heraldo de honduras
alarmante incremento de la mendicidad
infantil como consecuencia de la
pandemia en brasil- folha de sao paulo
decía esta misma semana que brasil es
uno de los dos países con menos tiempos
de aulas según la ocde en estos
instantes con una vida que resurge en
bares y playas y mientras la mayoría de
las escuelas está cerrada paola son los
jóvenes latinoamericanos esa generación
que ahora tendría entre 18 y 25 años
quienes van a pagar sobre todo esta
crisis yo respondería este pregunta con
matices porque sabe que la historia
latinoamericana no solamente no está en
la primera gran crisis han habido
dictaduras súper importantes que han
también sacrificados generaciones han
habido guerras civiles en centroamérica
que también han sacrificado generaciones
hoy día en las situaciones diferentes yo
sé que muchos jóvenes por ejemplo en
chile país que conozco bastante bien en
mi país también los jóvenes existen con
una frustración importante no sé si se
sienten que todo está perdido porque una
vez también se dice que mejor perderte
para mejor encontrarse en cierto que
vivía este gran paréntesis hay que
olvidar que chile por ejemplo llevan
meses confinados en santiago y en
diferentes lugares y seis meses de
encierro absoluto de aislamiento y ha
generado una cierta frustración de lo
que les depara en el futuro por ejemplo
hay ciertos sondajes que se han
realizado a través de minutos de
juventud nacional que cuál es el
sentimiento de la población chilena
sobre todo estos jóvenes entre 15 y 29
años y sobre todo ellos se manifiestan
con mucha inquietud respecto a su
situación económica que es una situación
de pobreza enorme que la vamos a hablar
más tarde y también respecto a sus
estudios mucha gente ha dejado de
estudiar porque no tiene la cabeza
disponible para poder hacer estas clases
a distancia tampoco tiene los medios
necesarios informáticos de conexión y
también para poder seguir estas clases a
distancia entonces yo no hablaría de
generación perdida porque insisto yo
pienso que la historia en nuestro de
nuestro continente nos ha dado razón
suficiente para pensar de que los
jóvenes y toda la gente de latinoamérica
tienen los recursos necesarios y
suficientes y una fuerza infinita para
poder reconstruirse no sé yo así desde
la economía hay indicios que pueden
mostra
a esa dirección de que nos encaminamos
hacia una generación perdida de jóvenes
en américa latina bueno es verdad que no
es la primera dificultad de la religión
del continente pero esta vez es un poco
diferente porque es probablemente la
mezcla más fuerte recesión de la región
en la reciente historia
nosotros en euler hermes prevemos una
contracción de la economía del pib de -6
7,5 por ciento y es un triple shock a
corto plazo había el shock del golpe del
comercio con china en principios del año
el golpe de los precios de materias
primas y también los el más grande el
golpe más grande el del confinamiento
que pone una pausa en la economía pues
es por primera vez por primera vez que
tenemos un golpe tan fuerte 13 golpes en
la economía que pueden tener este
impacto a largo plazo
el segundo mensaje es que bueno primero
el primero es la más fuerte a lización y
segundo los jóvenes ya estaban las
condiciones iniciales de los jóvenes que
ya estaban que no estaban muy muy buenas
porque si miramos a los datos de
desempleo en nuestros países
son cada vez el doble del desempleo
promedio nacional la media nacional por
ejemplo en brasil tenemos un desempleo
de los jóvenes de 20 75 por ciento
contra el 13% para el promedio y también
aparece como países como chile y
colombia son 20% pues mucho más que el
promedio nacional pues a causa de estos
de estas dos razones
hay una inquietud claro y es una crisis
de una naturaleza completamente
diferente
carlos que características específicas
económicas tiene esta crisis que no
tuvieran otras en el pasado de
latinoamérica es ese complementando las
las dos las dos descripciones
precedentes que son muy ajustadas si
dentro del marco de esta contracción que
es global es una de las contracciones
más grandes incluso comparado con la
epidemia de la gripe española que es
importante ver que ciertas
características cuál es el elemento
distintivo entre la reacción de los
países del norte y los países del sur me
parece que eso es importante para
entender lo que pasa con los jóvenes
jeff es fundamentalmente que la
cuarentena y la contracción de la
economía opera sobre una estructura
social diferente y esto los
centralizaría en el nivel de
informalidad la informalidad en la
región
es el país que tiene menor informalidad
es uruguay que está en torno del 25 por
ciento y los que tienen más informalidad
están en torno del 50 siendo brasil
argentina méxico o chile está en niveles
intermedios algunos países centroamérica
y porque esto es importante porque la
cuarentena corta los flujos de ingresos
de los sectores formales de los sectores
modernos hacia los sectores informales y
los sectores informales les llega con
más dificultad las ayudas que han sido
masivas eso es interesante a diferencia
del pasado en otras crisis en todos
estos países los programas fiscales han
sido gigantescos pero en los patrimonios
de los sectores informales son muy bajos
al día de manera que estos cortes por un
lado les cortan los flujos de consumo
agravan los efectos de demanda y la
recesión por el peso del sector informal
que es entre 25 y 30 por ciento de la
mano de obra y al mismo tiempo genera
desajustes en la vida social pero por
otra parte los informales tienen un
porcentaje de una de la ciudadanía que
vive en condiciones habitacionales muy
muy deficientes slams favelas villas
allí el hacinamiento es muy fuerte como
hacer una cuarentena con gente que vive
a cinco personas en un cuarto
esto genera desafíos muy importante que
podemos discutir en más detalle pero
creo que si tuviera que elegir un
elemento distintivo tomaría este
variedad la informalidad como elemento
radical pero infeliz yo le pregunta a
yanina también sí pero no hay que
olvidar que la desigualdad tremenda la
brecha salarial existe antes de esta
pandemia y eso justamente esta pandemia
ha puesto de manifiesto
las enormes desigualdades y la gente se
da un portazo tremendo para darse cuenta
que efectivamente vivimos en un
continente que es profundamente desigual
donde sistema neoliberal que ha se ha
implantado en muchos los países hoy día
está pasando la factura a la generación
de jóvenes y a los más fijos también
yanina web desde barcelona- yanina
nombraba a carlos vino a brad es
específicamente ese elemento de
informalidad claro muchos de los
universitarios que están dejando ahora
sus estudios fueron los primeros también
de sus familias que consiguieron llegar
a la universidad a la universidad pero
claro como estudias cuando pues no
tienes para sobrevivir
no vaya sí creo que la pregunta se
responde se responde eso la verdad o sea
el problema
en mi opinión es realmente dramático no
podemos pensar solamente en los jóvenes
no se hablaba de las dimensiones de la
crisis económica
la pobreza va a crecer y el foco creo
que ahí lo mencionaba paula también está
la desigualdad
cuando hablamos de si es sumamente
preocupante lo que está pasando con el
nivel universitario pero creo que es aún
más preocupante lo que está pasando en
los niveles primarios
en la educación básica y eso refuerza la
desigualdad algunas instituciones ya han
cuantificado incluso ese abandono de
matrículas que puede ser atención leo un
25 por ciento en el caso de colombia y
porcentajes parecidos en países de la
región según el centro de estudios
latinoamericano claro ese éxodo les
planteó amenaza a todo lo que ha habido
antes que es muchos años en muchos
países de la región haciendo muchísimos
esfuerzos por intentar dar pequeñísimos
pasos en lo que es la desigualdad en la
educación y también insisto no hay que
olvidar por ejemplo caso chileno la
gente se endeuda para poder que sus
hijos vayan a la escuela los estudiantes
universitarios se endeude para poder
pagar 5 años de estudio y seguir pagando
90 años después créditos que le vuelven
cuando son profesionales entonces ya la
situación de los estudiantes
en mi país es una estación precaria no
hay que olvidar que ha habido numerosas
más revoluciones de pingüinos en 2013
luego son de estudiantes para solicitar
una educación gratuita de calidad hoy
día que pone de manifiesto este esta
crisis de la pandemia y el confinamiento
de que efectivamente los estudiantes hoy
día están pensando por ejemplo hay
chicos que hacen clases y están en sumen
sus clases y les suena el teléfono y
tienen que hacer un delivery porque
están trabajando y estudiando al mismo
tiempo y el trabajo de delivery el les
sirve para pagar sus estudios y además
para poder pagar un poco y ayudar a la
economía a esa economía circular de su
familia donde por ejemplo el padre
perdió el trabajo informal del cual
hablaba carlos anteriormente porque en
chile por ejemplo en el sistema informal
de trabajo funciona todo el tiempo yo
creo que además este ejemplo que ha
puesto a paula es como muy visual no
todos no nos imaginamos ese caso del
chico al que le son el teléfono y tiene
que hacer un trabajo temporal bueno uno
de los problemas y porque la razón por
la que la educación es tan importante
también en algunos de esos países es que
la corrección de las desigualdades
ex-post después de ocurrido
no está tan buena en estos países pues
hay las desigualdades de oportunidad que
la educación corrige y también las ex
post que la los impuestos pueden
corregir y el problema es que los
sistemas de impuestos en nuestros países
la cepal de la onu dice que son seis
veces menos efectivos para corregir las
desigualdades que los de europa por
ejemplo y pues lo que puede hacer
latinoamérica es también reformar su
sistema de impuestos para corregir
después de ocurrido estas desigualdades
y un poco compensar esta importancia y
esta desigualdad de oportunidad con la
educación
quiero seguir avanzando en lo que supone
este éxodo sito en cambio es decir algo
si quisiera agregar si me permite es que
carlos mencionaba que ha habido ayudas
en los distintos países y eso es verdad
pero la pandemia también está poniendo
en evidencia un enorme problema de
capacidades estatales y no hay dos
ejemplos en perú por ejemplo se aprobó
la compra de tablets para acompañar el
proceso educativo pero sin embargo no se
pudieron comprar porque el procedimiento
estaba suficientemente aceitado y
pasados dos meses las tablets seguían
sin estar y lo mismo ha ocurrido en
guatemala con un paquete de ayudas sin
precedentes que a día de hoy tiene una
ejecución inferior al 20 por ciento me
pide la palabra carlos vino obra pero
espéreme un momentito porque vamos a
hacer una pequeña pausa y seguimos
analizando toda esta realidad de
generación perdida de jóvenes
latinoamericanos a vuelta de pausa quien
en primera
[Música]
a
en la región del magreb en el norte de
áfrica ha habido un fuerte incremento de
casos de kobe 19 especialmente en
marruecos que ya es el tercer país más
afectado del continente habiendo
superado los 75 mil casos positivos en
este país se están registrando alrededor
de 2000 casos diarios cifras que no se
habían alcanzado todavía desde el inicio
de la pandemia a los hospitales de las
regiones más afectadas se encuentran
saturados y se ha vuelto a prolongar el
estado de emergencia sanitaria también
mucha preocupación en libia un país
dividido y devastado por una guerra
multinacional desde hace casi una década
y cuyo sistema de salud se encuentra
hecho pedazos según datos que maneja el
gobierno de acuerdo nacional respaldado
por la onu se estarían registrando
alrededor de 1000 casos diarios pero
podrían ser muchos más porque no hay
datos de las zonas que no controla este
gobierno que son a gran parte del
territorio de libia en el caso de túnez
el país menos afectado de la región se
están volviendo a registrar centenares
de casos cada día y argelia es la
excepción es el país de la región donde
y los contagios diarios pero siguen
preocupando las muertes se han
registrado más de 1500 desde el inicio
de la pandemia y aun con menos contagios
que marruecos argelia es el país de la
región más afectado por la tasa de
mortalidad
[Música]
el pico de la pandemia parece ya haber
pasado en el sur de áfrica o al menos el
primer pico en sudáfrica se han
promediado más o menos 1000 casos
diarios en los últimos días lo cual es
sin duda una noticia de alivio aunque
las autoridades han llamado a no bajar
la guardia de hecho no se presentaron
altos repuntes en el número de casos
después de que se relajara el
confinamiento y tampoco he tenido que
usar si algunos de los hospitales de
campaña que se implementaron de manera
preventiva cuando estábamos en pleno
pico de la pandemia otros países de la
región como en la medio por ejemplo no
se han visto tan afectados namibia abrió
sus fronteras aunque las sudafricanas se
mantienen cerradas y en general la
región del áfrica subshariana se
esperaba que fuera una de las más
afectadas por la pandemia a nivel global
este no ha sido el caso y tanto los
expertos locales como internacionales
han admitido que encuentran inexplicable
este fenómeno el impacto económico sin
embargo en sudáfrica ya se pronosticaba
que iba a ser muy fuerte pero esta
semana obtuvimos por fin en cifras
oficiales y se ha dicho que la economía
del país se ha encogido en un 51 por
ciento lo cual es mucho más de lo
esperado y en parte las suspensiones en
las actividades de minería y de la costa
explican esta crisis económica
finalmente sudáfrica también ha
suspendido las pruebas clínicas con la
vacuna de la universidad de oxford
después de que se reportaran algunas
posibles complicaciones con este
tratamiento
cubre las historias de la gente con
nuestros reporteros por todo el planeta
nuestros periodistas van donde ocurre la
nutrición cada semana
reporteros le trae una historia inédita
no se lo pierdan
[Música]
acompáñenos en reporteros en cada semana
por france 24 y france 24 puntocom
estamos aquí en primera plan esta semana
analizando si estamos ante una
generación de jóvenes perdidos en
américa latina' raíz de la pandemia lo
hacemos con paula martínez infante
periodista independiente george vive
economista carlos vino gratis de la
escuela de economía de parís y de la
universidad de frei y giannina
investigadora del centro albert
hirschman en ginebra antes de irme a la
pausa él iba a dar paso a al señor
vinograd estamos hablando de esas
consecuencias del éxodo de estudiantes
en la región a causa de la pandemia
carlos si yanina hacía mención a algo
que me parece central que es las
capacidades estatales y en esto hay
mucha diversidad y es muy interesante el
caso de diferentes países
durante los años que podríamos haber
llamado la nueva belle époque de los
precios las materias primas la
desigualdad y la pobreza se redujo de
manera en algunos países más sensibles
que en otros la gran pregunta es si este
proceso se puede sostener ahora que ese
puig de ingresos de los estados sea el
licuado en en el tema de capacidades hay
un fenómeno que desatendemos y es que
paradójicamente uno de los sectores más
golpeados hoy son los sectores medios
bajos y no los sectores más bajo de la
sociedad porque porque se implementaron
planes como bolsa familia como progress
en brasil como progresa en méxico
etcétera que consiguieron llegar a los
sectores más excluidos la sociedad la
pandemia desconectó a los informales
medios peluqueros taxistas que no
corresponden a estos sectores y que no
tienen planes y que además esto es un
tema complejo que no es de la economía
que no tienen hábitos de recibir ayuda o
solicitar ayuda al estado estos sectores
que son
fracciones sensibles de la sociedad
profesionales liberales en carrera
intermedia se ven en una situación de
sándwich completamente comprimido por un
efecto tenaza la capacidad del estado de
llegar allí es baja y estos sectores
tienen dificultad de acercarse en esto
creo que hay algunos ejemplos por
ejemplo es la eficacia de uruguay que es
un caso del cual se habla que tiene un
sistema de estatal mucho más poroso que
llega más abajo que ha conseguido hacer
una cuarentena más corta que tiene un
sistema de cobertura desempleo más
eficiente y que ha tenido que cerrar las
escuelas por menos tiempo en todo este
conjunto de capacidades estatales me
parece que tiene que ver con lo que dice
yanina hay países como argentina que
conozco que tiene un gran capital de
herencia tienen niveles
capital sanitario es decir camas por
habitantes respiradores y médicos que no
son muy lejanos son muy cercanos a los
países europeos pero cuando tiene que
operar ayudas alimentarias se pierden no
llegan y están todos los programas
completamente trancados o por problemas
de gestión o corrupción o por problemas
simplemente que no operan me parece que
el tema de yanina y centrarse es muy
interesante yanina paola george es ese
punto que hace referencia carlos de los
informales medios no de ellos los que no
tienen posibilidades y al mismo tiempo
no están acostumbrados a esas
subvenciones del estado y se encuentran
en esa situación tan complicada ahora no
y por esa misma razón por ejemplo el
gobierno de piñera realizó un plan
report alecio para la clase media en la
cual que fue la que más ha sido afectada
también por éste por esta pandemia donde
la gente perdió o tenía un trabajo
formal pero perdido en el informal que
le permitía tener un cierto grado de
confortabilidad digamos salarial a fin
de mes para poder pagar todo lo que hay
que pagar por querer cambiar que en
chile la educación hay que pagarla la
salud es un sistema privado que vale una
fortuna también en los fondos de
pensiones también
a una fortuna entonces el nivel de medio
de ingresos de una clase media es muy
bajo en chile entonces es cierto que hoy
día todos los programas que han hecho
subsidio de arriendo subsidio de
salarios que lo va a anunciar el
presidente piñera en un par de días más
creo en todo ese contexto es la clase
media hoy día que no está habituada como
bien dice carlos a recibir estas ayudas
sociales que se encuentra como un
sandwich entremedio de aquellos que
tienen holgadamente su salero fin de año
o sea de fin de mes perdón que no tienen
ninguna dificultad económica y aquellos
que están acostumbrados no acostumbrados
pero más bien han tenido totalmente un
plan social que les ha ayudado a salir
un poco la extrema pobreza sin embargo
perdona justo para terminar y es eso lo
importante que hoy día el concepto de
clase media también se ha perdido porque
la clase media digamos que de manera
absoluta no existe porque hay un
empobrecimiento de esa clase media que
ha perdurado desde los últimos 30 años
en todos lados también yanina dada esta
situación que estamos describiendo
de cara a los próximos meses qué
políticas deberían implementar los
diferentes estados de américa latina
para paliar cómo se pueda o evitar que
estas consecuencias que estamos
describiendo para toda esta generación
de jóvenes
es muy complejo y no soy la persona
indicada o no sé si es posible si
quieres dar una respuesta para todos los
países de la región
podemos también digo en particular por
lo que señalaba carlos en relación a las
capacidades estatales diferenciales
yo creo que países con una burocracia
más eficiente o un poco más eficiente
pueden implementar ciertas medidas y
países con una discapacidad total en
esos recursos tienen que buscar otras
ahora volviendo al tema de los jóvenes y
en los ejemplos concretos ayer nos
comentaban en una decisión sobre
guatemala qué
un mes de internet en guatemala cuesta
lo mismo o sea el pago de la cuota de
internet que un año de matrícula
universitaria ahí tienes una política
muy clara
pero pero insisto también no hay que
perder de vista que la educación
primaria o sea la educación
universitaria también el acceso es
restringido en unos países más que en
otros entonces no hay que incrementar
las desigualdades tiene que ver una
política bastante holística que permita
por ejemplo
dar mayores accesos de conectividad a
los universitarios que podrían acceder a
una educación mixta o online y no perder
de vista que hay que ir reabriendo a
escuelas y ahí es donde está la clave
eso creo yo que es necesario reabrir
escuelas y europa no está haciendo las
condiciones no son las mismas hay que
pensarlo muy bien pero hay que apostar a
eso y completar un poco las respuestas y
los puntos muy justos que fueron hechos
a propósito de las diferencias en las
respuestas presupuestarias y monetarias
entre países de europa o de estados
unidos y países de américa latina cuando
miramos a los
del banco central que intenta ver
cuántas medidas fueron adoptadas por los
diferentes países cuál es la parte de
estas medidas que es dirigida a proteger
los empleos lo que vemos es que en
países de europa y de eeuu es más de del
30% hasta el 70% de todas las medidas
todas las avenidas que son dirigidas
para proteger los empleos en américa
latina en perú chile economía son menos
de 20 por ciento pues lo que podemos
aconsejar orientaciones de políticas
públicas son un interés en realizaciones
para reintegrar a la gente inactiva
después de esta crisis al mercado
laboral con políticas activas del
mercado laboral para paliar este efecto
de desempleo porque los países de
américa latina vieron sus desempleo sus
tasas aumentar muy fuertemente disparar
en esta crisis comparado con otros
países de europa donde los empleos se
mente mantengan
gracias a las políticas del gobierno
toda esta situación y les quiero
preguntar a todos ha supuesto una
frustración sin duda para los jóvenes
sus primeros empleos sus estudios sus
amistades no sé si podríamos decir que
este 2020 paula está siendo un año de
frustración para los jóvenes de américa
latina y como se esté como calibramos es
elemento de la frustración que a lo
mejor va más allá de los datos
económicos que estamos exponiendo que es
cierto que hay que salir un poco de los
datos macroeconómicos porque en realidad
es que son micros que son mucho más
duras en reales
de lo que estamos conversando acá en la
cual hay gente hay gente en chile que se
prefieren ir del cómic y morir de hambre
por ejemplo todos los adultos que lo
dicen son también los jóvenes y los
menos jóvenes todo el mundo hoy día se
siente una situación de trampa absoluta
de una trampa social donde hay un
sistema social de protección social en
ciertos países que es muy deficitario
que aunque que no funciona entonces yo
pienso que hoy día esa frustración que
se genera en la sociedad nos es insisto
todavía en chile no hay que olvidar que
hubo un estudio social que comenzó en
octubre que ya ponía de manifiesto todas
las desigualdades y los problemas que
había en la economía del país que
generaba enormes desigualdades
no tenía para comer no tenía para
educarse no tenía dinero para vivir
decentemente entonces qué hace esta
crisis efectivamente ha dado insisto un
cachetazo a todo este sistema liberal
neoliberal donde han tirado por la
ventana los servicios básicos a la
educación la salud y hoy día los
gobiernos están por ejemplo en el no de
piñera en vez de tomar medidas
preventivas hace acciones inmediatas
para poder paliar no sabemos lo que ha
pasado más adelante hoy día es cierto
hay gente que yo puede entrevistar aquí
haya diferentes de diferentes estratos
sociales que sienten que ha sido un año
un poco perdido un poco perdido
unións no se sabe qué va a pasar más
adelante pero si hay una frustración
enorme porque toda la reivindicación que
había comenzado en octubre fue parada
por la pandemia esperan que en octubre
con el plebiscito que se va a hacer a
fin a fin de fines de octubre para
cambiar la constitución y abrir nueva
perspectiva las cosas puedan volver a
funcionar y puedan volver a marchar esta
máquina de la reivindicación social que
es muy importante la niña como valora
usted ese fenómeno ese elemento de la
frustración más allá
de los datos económicos
bueno coincido con lo que decía paula
hay que verlo a nivel micro y creo que
ahí ahí hay muchas diferencias también
en la situación el escenario político
que está viviendo cada país por un lado
quizás en chile la perspectiva del
plebiscito añada cierta ilusión sobre
todo los jóvenes que han estado muy
movilizados en las protestas y dependen
de muchos países hay incorporaría quizás
las variables de la democracia que
veníamos viendo que el apoyo a la
democracia está disminuyendo en la
región y preocupa especialmente que los
jóvenes perciban que la política no es
capaz de transformar cosas creo que ahí
también hay que trabajar tanto el relato
como la eficiencia de las políticas
públicas para que se fortalezca refuerce
o restablezca la confianza a la política
carlos no se quiere añadir algo más
sobre esa percepción o ese desencanto
que puede incluso incrementarse a partir
de ahora en esa generación de jóvenes
latinoamericanos
en esto la seguiría un poco la línea de
humildad
de yanina el problema es muy complejo
por un lado las cuarentenas protegen
vidas actuales y por otro lado generan
problemas futuros más allá de la de la
frustración de los sectores medios hay
algo que no que la política tiene mucha
dificultad para gestionar y que es lo
que yo llamo vidas y vidas se protegen
vidas actuales pero por ejemplo los
sectores más desfavorecidos ya no los
sectores medios que hablábamos antes
sino los sectores bajos nuevamente va a
haber problemas en la próxima generación
por los problemas de pérdida de ingresos
que están siendo muy prolongados porque
hasta que no llegue la vacuna la
perturbación de la vida social va a
continuar y los chicos ya no son los
adolescentes estos chicos van a tener
problemas alimentarios nutricionales
sabemos que las aptitudes cognitivas y
educativas futuras van a ser afectadas
no somos el áfrica de manera que la
malnutrición no genera
una por ahora mayor mortalidad infantil
pero tenemos un problema problema que la
política es difícil que responda porque
las elecciones son periodos cortos y
tiene que responder a la ansiedad de las
muertes de hoy tenemos que dejarla de
carlos porque me quedo sin tiempo les
hemos propicia un montón de elementos a
los telespectadores para que puedan
valorar esta generación perdida américa
latina' muchísimas gracias a los cuatro
ya todos ustedes hasta la próxima semana
en primera plana